The European Union has launched its mission
to help Ukraine reform its civilian security
sector - police, border authorities, intelligence
services and justice system.
From the capital Kyiv, dozens of senior officials
and officers from around Europe are working
to build trust with their counterparts in
Ukraine’s interior ministry, the security
sector, and courts.
This is not a training mission, nor is anyone
armed. It’s about providing strategic advice
to Ukrainian officials on anything to do with
the rule of law, except for defence matters.
By March, more than 100 international and about 75 local staff
are due to be working from the EU Advisory
Mission’s new headquarters, counselling
and mentoring officials in Ukraine’s civilian
security sector.
For the moment, the search for the right building
goes on, just one of EUAM’s many challenges.
In the few months since a fact-finding team
arrived, staff have been talking with their
local counterparts and civic partners - listening,
forging relationships, trying to understand
how best to help Ukraine, even as conflict
simmers in the east.
SOUNDBITE - Kalman Mizsei, EUAM Ukraine Head of Mission
“It's not an easy job. It's going to take
a lot of time. How far we go in two years,
nobody at this moment can tell."
Trust must be re-established between the police
forces and the people. Public confidence was
never particularly high, but the heavy police
handling of the pro-European Maidan rallies
a year ago made things worse.
Corruption is the biggest challenge the EU
mission faces. Low wages, a lack of checks
and balances, and a vertical structure that
leaves the policeman on the street unaware
of interior ministry priorities provide room
for corruption to flourish.
Ukraine is setting up an anti-corruption bureau
to help restore confidence.
For it to work, EU officials say, policies
must be clear and transparent, with easy public
access to reliable information. It’s a problem
that cannot be fixed overnight.
SOUNDBITE - Mika Aalto, EUAM Ukraine Anti-corruption
Advisor
“Ukrainian society is vulnerable for corruption,
there is no doubt about that. We all are aware
about the fact. But I think that the biggest
problem is that normal people, they don't
trust the decisions-makers. And we need to
find ways in order to convince the decision-makers
to make such decisions so that Ukrainian people
can find the trust in the Ukrainian authorities
again."
While the effects of the conflict are not
obvious in Kyiv, the fighting does bring social
tensions, and internally displaced people.
Still, the government remains willing to reform
the security sector.
Reform of agencies like the traffic police
is being carried out under the Association
Agreement that is the foundation stone of
Ukraine’s relations with the European Union.
That means getting EUAM staff as close as
possible to all the security wings, including
the intelligence service, the riot police,
or the border guards.
Ukraine has 7,000 kilometres of borders,
about a third of that shared with Russia.
The border police were the first hit by the
conflict. They seem optimistic about cooperating
with the European mission.
SOUNDBITE - Colonel Yulia Petrova, Ukraine
State Border Guard Service
"The Ukrainian border guards are very committed
to move on reforms toward European standards.
And we really hope this EU mission will be
of great help to do that, and to achieve this
goal."
But this is just the start. EUAM is a long-term
project. The mission has a two-year mandate
and a first-year budget of just over 13 million
euros. Staff will conduct a strategic assessment
in 12 months.
For now, the focus is on building relationships
and establishing trust, between the EU mission
and the Ukrainian security sector, but also
on restoring citizens’ confidence in their
forces of order.
Because people expect change. They want assurances
that Ukraine’s security forces have turned
their backs on the old ways of the past.